Never have I ever checked you out
while you were changing.
You checked me out though,
did it?
I haven't seen you in ages. Oh No.
It's just been like 10 minutes.
My name is Jonathan.
I am 25 my name is Maddie.
I'm 28 seven. I what? That was all hard.
I've actually known
him before he was born,
but we didn't really hang out up until
like he moved in. I think so. Yeah.
You go first here. Let's do it. It
never have I ever made
you clean up my mess.
Three, two, one.
That time when I got really sick.
Oh,
I never seen come from anyone lives.
It was like you were like, you were being
exercise. It was just like how like,
like you are this really gross,
but I really appreciate it.
You guys for that though. I
love you man. So I do the same.
I think for me, uh, it's definitely the
dishes, dude. I do my dishes all the time,
but sometimes you get lazy.
Yeah, yeah, for sure.
Never have I ever hit on your friends,
Yo, man, you bring the girls all the time.
When we're supposed to do I just
want to sit there and be quiet now.
I wouldn't be able to. Oh, I haven't.
Mainly because I haven't really met a
lot of like you don't bring friends that
are on the light. Right. Cause I
figured you guys would hit on him.
So honestly I'm not surprised though.
Like I
give it to me, give it to me. Never
have I ever pretended not to be home.
So you wouldn't talk to me.
Wait, really? I mean like
you guys are family to me. You know
I was, I grew up an only child.
So being able to have a roommate or a
group of roommates that are like that are
like family to me. Like that's dope. God,
thanks for making me feel like now I
don't go to like extremes in pretending
like I don't go into the closet and
close off the lines of hope. Like,
oh I hope they don't
notice I don't do that.
But now there's times when you know,
you just want to be just like, man,
I feel like I'd be not a good
person to talk to you right now.
So I stay away no matter what.
Like if you guys wanted to talk to me,
even if it feels like it, should
they? Yeah. I mean I feel the same.
I'm still all ears.
Yeah.
Damn
bond they're not is man. Let's do it.
We're going deep now.
Never have I ever checked you
out while you were changing.
You checked me out though. Did like
we're an apartment of guys like, yeah.
How thins check your arms and your
hands. Want to see it. Some progress,
the gym and all that steak objectively,
I feel we're all good looking
people in the apartment,
so like you're trying to see if another
bonding moment. It's a bonding moment
and then let's just say we
know each other too well.
Okay.
Never have I ever lied to you.
Okay. Three, two, one.
I was like, boy, you got to
lie right here, Huh? Yes.
Yes.
Someone's,
you've lied to everyone at some point
in life like you're talking about like
white lies. Yeah, exactly.
Okay. Okay. Then let me ask you,
what's the biggest lie
you've ever told me then
I was okay.
Oh, you asked me about my
mental health. Gotcha. Yeah.
Cause I guess at the point I was
just trying to be like I was,
I just wanted to get through stuff on
my own aggression. That's understood.
I didn't want it to,
I didn't want to trouble you guys,
which I guess is stupid in mice.
Right.
Cause I don't have real trouble
when you're even when you knew.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
I definitely lied to you for sure. Yeah.
You know, white lies and all that stuff.
And the same thing when you guys
asked me how I'm doing whatever.
Sometimes I lie because I don't
want to get into it or whatever. Um,
I mean for you,
I'm glad that we were able
to like eventually like I
was able to eventually get
past that and able to, I
guess truly open up. Yeah.
Never have I ever been jealous of you.
Three, two, one. All right.
[inaudible] all these
chips that jut Pam module.
Okay. Why are you jealous of that? Because
you want to go right? I'll go next time.
We're going next time.
All right. I'm just like,
I'm sure we're eventually
going to put you in a suitcase.
You don't have enough money.
I guess it's my turn. Huh?
What are you doing?
Why the fuck are you so good looking dude,
I'm sorry.
I'm not doing,
I think you're,
you're a smart guy and a all that stuff.
So when you do work on like, you know, you
probably do this stuff. I was like, man,
I admire then, but yeah. Cool. I'll
take you on next week. Let's do it.
Let's do it.
Let's see what's happening.
Never have I ever been
ashamed to tell you something.
Three, two, one.
You remember that time when
I had broken up with my ex?
Yeah.
Yeah Dude.
I was definitely a shame to tell you guys
that I was still hanging out with her.
Um, and it was like selective, you know,
it was like I would only
come to you because um,
those are things I could
tell you. Yeah. I mean I get,
that's why like I was always there for
you whenever you wanted to talk. You were,
yeah. I'm glad that you feel
comfortable coming to me,
us, that stuff kind of is my team.
It is your turn. Trying
to drag it out. Shaved
things I've been ashamed of.
I guess it would be like when I had
that in my shame to tell us that
no one's ever really proud of when
they're not in a good mental spot. Right.
I knew I could come to you guys and
with that kind of stuff, but it's still,
it's still something you're
kind of ashamed of. Nah, man,
you shouldn't feel ashamed, man. That's
what we're here for. Yeah. Like I said,
yeah. Like I, like I said to Peter, man,
it's what would I do without
you exactly what I mean. And,
and I hope you can say the
same thing to you know, is now,
it really is like you brought up on a
really great point where it's just like
all those times where, where would I be
if you were gone and stuff like that.
Or if any of my roommates, yeah. Dude,
I tell you like we're pretty
lucky in that sense. All right.
To have such a big support
group. Yeah, yeah, no,
definitely. Yeah. That's
alright. That's alright dude.
Never have I ever cried
at the house. Three, two,
one.
We've all cried from joy
from a lot of laughing.
A lot of, Oh, a lot of laughing.
A lot of emotions. That too loud,
heavy emotions, man. We're
emotional people. Yeah.
I feel like this like period of my life
has really changed who I am as a person.
This is a very pivotal moment is to 10.
Yeah,
I'm definitely gonna if we ever,
you know,
I'm pretty sure we'll go our
separate ways, but uh, you know,
really fun memory.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
High five to good times.
Hey,
are you guys,
Jason from Juba here?
You just want to say thank you
so much for watching that video.
We hope you enjoyed it. We also want to
say a huge thank you to our sponsors.
Squarespace. Uh, if you don't know,
Squarespace is an all in one platform
where you can build a website,
you can build an online store,
you can even buy a domain.
And for all of our viewers,
if you visit squarespace.com/jubilee
you'll not only get a free travel,
you also get 10% off your first purchase.
Who doesn't want 10% off?
Um, as always, thank you so much for
watching. Make sure you subscribe here.
Watch more of our videos here
and we'll see you next time. Bye.